[Music]
so hi my name is Kelvin me I'll be
teaching the viewers choice class this
week into the bear Hanson because he was
filling away to go to dinner so I'm 18
years old I'm a 2100 USDF after my
latest tournament and we'll be going
over a game from the spring classic that
happened here in st. Louis between a
wonder Lea or a Wonder and wonderment so
it started
efore see 693 be five silver caro-kann
after Knight f3 we have the two knights
variation so this should be for h3
Bishop f3 Queen f3 and e 6 so this is
all pretty standard stuff I'm going to
move here's Knight f6 which immediately
puts pressure on this pawn and a way
this could continue like b5 pushing the
knight back and we'd get some line here
with like a 60s could be pretty nasty
but anyways ethics is played so why
continue development with d4 black now
played Knight f6 and 53 just supporting
the central pawn here so blacks idea
basically is that you get a French
structure like this but you have no
horrible bishop on c8 right because
usually in the French the bane of your
existence is getting this bishop to do
something useful but in this case it's
traded so fall for the knight on f3
which can often turn into a powerful
piece so the game continues in 64 and I
take C 4 so in exchange for getting rid
of this Bishop Black has wasted a tempo
plank c6 in a sense whereas usually
you'll play c5 in the French and so in
this line black is giving up his central
pawn in some space in order to make this
exchange pieces
so after it takes and recaptures queen
takes d4 winning upon all right so white
castle and black captures on e4 and
there's some crazy lines here and the
notations all right what is there a
glove to live so apparently in previous
games night BB 7 has been played and
this is you can scan Darrell's versus
come Kamra cool of very exciting
alright so nigh bd7 and the skin
continued rook e1 Bishop e7 we should be
3 Queen B 4 so it looks like white is
activating all of his pieces and with
tempo against black screen in exchange
for the central beep on so this can
continued C 3 and context b2 isn't the
best of ideas because of this line well
let's see what do you guys think white
could play after connects me to so yeah
it just tricks everyone and if black
tries to grab another pawn I imagine
earth takes b7 it's going to be very
strong
so this b7 pawn is actually critical
because now t6 is falling and this King
is a lot less safe for the right number
7 so maybe it's something like castles
how could I continue continue here to a
really sick the nail in the coffin in
the black solution obviously that's one
way just training off these pieces and
then like lose beat yeah that's right
okay
so black would have to continue with
Pont eggs and from here how do you think
watch your spawned there are a few
tempting moves a few very tempting news
right so how might that LIGO so Bishop
takes skin takes and then obviously the
Czech king g8 and is there a maid here
work d4 maybe f5 is holding together for
the moment with this bishop covering the
critical dark squares and this pawn
playing some defense so maybe instead
just taking the knight back should be
simple enough right
down no material this King's going to
going to fold pretty soon this Bishop
really can't be defended like the only
safe square for this Bishop is on a3
which I'm not sure makes so much sense
to be placing your pieces on a3 when
your Kings under attack and then f7 will
just hang so yet black that's something
you have to watch out for uh you don't
want to get too greedy in opening a
special like this where White's already
up so much in development and on the
caro-kann a lot of the time this opening
this be follow for whites rook just
results in disaster so what happens
instead here looks like Queen a5 was the
move that was chosen so white continues
with B for the Queen your shaded c7 and
white continued playing the tempo
against this Queen with Bishop f4 so
what do you convey idea blind Queen c7
ones it's black knew that Bishop f4 was
coming anyways
right that's right so this pawn
structure for black with b-66 b7 that f7
is very solid but in order to break out
of wipes attacking chances you're
eventually going to break with c5 or e5
depending on the position so in this
case black wanted to play e5 to give us
pieces in space and control some
critical squares like d4 and f4 so
Bishop g5 was played um and then after
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes you seven
team takes e7 Queen takes d4 now black
cherries off some pieces so White's
attack is much less I'll intimidating I
would say because we go back a few moves
this Bishop in this Knight are both
sorry before E 5 this Bishop in this
night both really line up nicely against
blacks dark squares for example
something like Queen b8 here
96 would of course be terrible forcing
Bishop d6
we should take these six and then this
King is stuck in the center districts on
the same file at the Queen and I mean
the two bishops are just way too strong
here the e5 is a very critical move I
would say so
Bishop e5 94 which Bishop e7 King 7
Queenie 4 so black continued to break
out in this line with Knight to f6 Queen
e3 and just getting on the open file so
it looks to me as though black is up a
healthy pawn but the White has a good
Bishop in exchange for it and this King
is still stuck in the center which isn't
quite where it would like to be this
game when Bishop c4 b6 rook e1 e for
Bishop d3 Queenie fives take take take
take
and they agreed to a draw shortly after
dad that was actually between Mahmoud
Mammadov versus navara all right but
anyways anyways this entire line was
avoided from this move so instead of the
standard night bd7
which we've seen a couple times ah sorry
beside yeah Knight takes e4 is play
instead of the standard 90 d7 so white
of course recaptured 97 was played
Bishop f4 just developing the pieces
aiming at these blue star squares that
black has created since playing east 6
and 3 6 so here rip to c8 was played as
sort of a mysterious move to me but yeah
I suppose just trying to gain control of
some of these dark squares and prepare
things like c5 in the future or possibly
be fives in the future or b6 is
something Y could be thinking about with
in which case you would need support for
the C pawn so Rick ID 1 of course
getting a tempo on the Queen Queen to f6
or Kathy 1 and night c5
so another option it looks like what
what do you think another option could
have been hearing remember black schools
nobody's up upon he wants to trade down
some pieces and gain some more space for
themselves to try and counteract some of
this activity and these bishops the
White has yeah c5 is a move that black
would like to play but the reason it
wasn't played in this game is because
white has a very strong move here you'd
think like something like Bishop g3 for
example between six up three Bishop
takes f3 and block could be doing fine
here because the Queen's are off you're
probably not going to get checkmated and
you can complete your development
without too many issues with even
something like f6 I'm just supporting
upon but the issue is white doesn't move
this Bishop because I can make a
stronger threat so what might that be
Rick technique seven is a very
interesting move um yeah you have your
along the right track
why it's trying to get at this King but
the issue here is you're just a little
bit too slow for example kingi eight
here and then if you try to follow up
with some sort of checkmate or at da's
and time I think but your clothes your
clothes yeah yeah queen g4 immediately
yeah so the point is you're stepping out
of this pin the black hat on your queen
so now you can move your bishop freely
with no issues and if black dares to
take here of course this is checkmate
immediately
so yeah this would actually probably be
disaster for black because black would
have to do something like Knight b6 or
rip to d8 to step out of this and if 58
obviously Bishop e5 wins material
immediately and if something like 96
Bishop takes e5 would be a very strong
move Nathan's a knight is no longer
defending the e pawn
you can't recapture because of hooks
which are some way very well placed to
take the black King say that's why you
five wasn't played sorry look like a
little too far
so black instead decided to play 95
attacking your bishop so actually very
good move because white can't move this
bishop anywhere to save it so keeping in
mind that white needs to act with some
urgency to maintain his advantage after
you're sacrificing upon how can we keep
blacks from developing his pieces or
even in a broader sense continue to like
move with tempo making threats with each
move so this is definitely a critical
point like when you're sacrificing a
central pawn like this you definitely
need all of your moves to have a very
distinct purpose or else black will just
do all the pieces and be able trouble
right you preserve the bishops in this
line but I'm not so sure you want to be
trading Queens because yeah now that the
Queens are off bless King in the center
looks a lot more well placed well not
even well place but let's poorly placed
then in post and blacks to them is still
opera here but maybe something like f6
which is always an ugly move and I would
hate to hear Ben Feingold critique me
but at 6 mix a lot of sense here because
once the bishop has to move which I'm
not sure we want to put the bishop if
you put on g6 I'll take conflicting 7 if
you come this way
my plan is to play King f7 sort of
artificially castling well actually
that's probably not the best moves in
this case because you know white can
play d4 in the north be 7 and things get
very ugly
but uh yeah but yeah I'm not sure I
think why it would like to keep the
Queens on to preserve his advantage
because I no matter how you look at it
you are just down upon in this position
so if you're not getting something very
concrete it's tough to justify hey you
want to keep up the pressure while
limiting peace trades
so what squares do you weaken when you
put all your squares all your Punggol my
squares now you've leaving the dark
squares so in this case white wants to
attack the dark squares with Queen g3
Queen e3 is another idea but the direct
threat this was making is Bishop to e5
when g7 might be hanging but maybe not
due to some tactics and also Bishop d6
when you ever take that bishop quintics
or for example say black cake and then
does nothing oh yeah and then there's
nothing you're just going to get
destroyed along the dark squares after
something like Bishop g5 point xb2
and there has to be some mate here but
it just Queen to b3 it's probably more
than enough when the Queen feeding into
d7 or d8 and everything is checkmate
I'll bring some is another very very
nice move very fancy
so of course yeah of course is Queens
off-limits because of her da checkmate
so look flip back to the notation here
should actually happen after Queen to g3
black did not take this bishop and
instead went pawn grabbing which I'm not
so sure about this I'm not so sure about
this so Wow all right a lot of hunting
options after after your opponent goes
hunting for phones but in the game white
chose to save this Bishop with Bishop to
f5 because now since the pen and what a
black up some more poems which alright
now how should we continue
let's identify some critical squares
right so this spawn is obviously
critical right because if this pawn were
to go away this rook would be a monster
and your king would be checkmated so
because this pawn is so critical you
would like to be attacking it as many
times with his few defenders on it this
nice defending well and it's straight
now the screen is defending it and you
only have this bishop in the circuit at
hand so how can you get more pieces
attacking e6 and just bringing them
closer to the King in general
yeah Bishop d6 era is a very strong move
so Bishop takes d6 which obviously is a
horrible move of course Queen takes e6
and all of the checkmates are very
apparent you have to play something like
d6 there's something terrible in order
to not lose a knight and then here I'm
not so sure that works immediately
I actually I think the problem the
problem is pawn takes right and how do
you engineer
yeah so maybe the sort of
counterintuitive well actually no the
great move and yeah that's one of us
what suggest but I think after Queen d5
you just don't have too much here
Queens are being traded this is sort of
insane
very difficult to believe that why it's
not just winning no this didn't happen
ah so Bishop takes c6 was implied which
obviously we've no immediately wind that
clearly looks very very bad instead
black responded with Queen to a5 so
trying to bring his queen back to defend
some of the dark squares defending this
night so then the game continued this
should take c5 so again removing
defenders of the d6 pawn Queen takes d5
and the SAC was played so f-86 or 66
Bishop e7 let's played apparently King
f7 was another one and how might white
continue hearing this is not as easy as
you might imagine to give checkmate
the king can be very slippery right yeah
clean we're b3 yeah alright so okay
first of all Richard you seven is a Matt
point right because I think you can
actually go to taking this and suddenly
wipe out of pieces to attack with if you
try checking yeah if you try checking
just screen block and there's no fancy
distraction tricks because this Bishop
covers all but and so Queen b3 seems
like a nice moves very sure Queen d5
might be the move it seems kind of
ridiculous but oh oh yeah verse 37 might
might be good somehow somehow someway
I'm searching for defense but I think
even uh I think grenade to here is the
winning move choose well actually I
guess Queenie sixes force
okay but Nobby yes well this is
ridiculous clearly just clearly just
corn up three no need for such shame and
you're just meeting on f7
well maybe h6 or something insane but I
can hardly I can hardly imagine hi
well you're not you're definitely not
looking for a perpetual here but yeah
Queen a 226 ah man this is unbelievable
all right there's another window there's
another one so let's let's find a simple
one
so what's the main problem here
yeah their work is same so can you solve
this problem with tempo
yeah just tricky five right so black
will have to move is Queen way and now
d7 q g8 I'm not actually sure Queen of
three sings like a reasonable move it's
not the move
Erica's here but I think the issue is
this Queen already attends the critical
square here and if you're not careful
you're just down a piece there are some
assert absurd moves though that I'm
noticing such as your p5 oh sorry it's
black smooth even but yeah if it were
right to move here there would be some
observers such as your to be five but
I'll maybe hh5 is enough for the moment
probably h6 rather just creating a
flight square and again it's tough to
win so sorry at 47 kg 8 ah you're very
close you're very close so the problem
with this is yet something like Queen d4
protects g7 and then
yeah well check
first of all Queen d5o excuse me but
second of all yeah just Queen d5 there's
no second of all any other moves
checkmate but Queen d5 officers but you
have the right idea so the idea is black
is a very difficult time defending this
pawn well earth takes pawn is a little
ambitious because after takes and
something like rook g5 here just clean
up seven defend but yeah like you're
saying your g5 immediately is a the way
aired game so now if you try something
like going to d4 excuse me yeah sorry
yeah if the Queen defense that sideways
as well I don't like the one I saw was
actually Queen b3 after Queen d4 but of
course they're just mix backwards so
well g6 you just you just breakthrough
immediately again yeah but yeah so this
is why King to f7 it's no good after the
sacrifice you can't play here because
you lose so instead Bishop to e7 was
plays and now can we find the next move
uh yeah that's totally reasonable
let me see was actually play - Lee oh my
goodness
egg is giving 30 lines okay sorry those
are the camps other mines right Queen d7
makes a lot of sense
maybe it's a bit slow because why would
it be a bit slow because to work the f8
and now don't get it don't get too uh
too antsy here because block has some
thread okay right and maybe you're
getting checked a few too many times
maybe not actually Ron each one hmm okay
maybe I shouldn't be taking this EFT on
so quickly but perhaps you're sure that
700 other things yeah the other will
also work as long
you can defend you you black those have
more bishops which is very very
difficult to get around
so yeah just the tricky one immediately
and and now your queen is still guarding
a c7 scratch it turned out very
important so I think Eric gave another
one here which is to apply repeat five
first and after Queen B four to play c3
so the idea is you're trying to drive
the screen away from the defense between
a three and now can take g7 and after
Rick f8 quick stage seven eight six we
need six check rift f7 is getting very
nasty and it's very difficult to the
center against all of these two it's so
this is where Eric ended this line it
probably ended the line here because
Queen the g8 is a very very nasty move
and how to select the fun you can't move
the rook because your Queens on pretty
and you can't move the bishop is after
this now you have to move the rook and
the same issue remains it's a very very
nasty idea by Eric okay so black smell
the danger as you can believe probably
sitting across the board here I might be
a little bit afraid of some of these
lines so you try to cast a lot of it so
of course giving back the bishop but
White's also done a couple couple Queen
aside pounds over here which is nothing
to be ashamed about
so black continue with rip to f7 which
eric has a few lines here that like it
applied will go over the main line
search
how would you respond as weight to this
just clean d5 there right between b3
Queen d5 breaking the country there's
one check exam oh right yes print takes
pawn is also mmm I wouldn't I'm not so
sure that's actually okay for a black
but it could be did you have some
serious background is shoes as well
right so the King's exposed so yeah with
the idea of
I just thinking upon right oh no not
taking upon yeah this would probably be
fine for light I can't imagine it's
terrible but maybe there's something
better that's an interesting idea right
maybe Queen d5 there would be okay for
black just blocking off the diagonal so
King to g8 is legal after it destiny
you're on the right track I have a still
work to do
right right so Queen e6 first okay so
this the idea is now the screen can
never come here because of this art will
first of all the risk effect and then
when the Queen comes here you'll always
have like Queen c7 check so black played
route to b8 yeah it's just hanging right
that would be checkmate oh yeah so I'm
pretty sure yeah lifting the rope and
then giving checkmate there's something
you have to be careful of no I think
it's fine all right
yeah dystrophy 561 King h2 Queen b6
trying to convince but yeah just
checkmate
stop someone checkmate not quite the
other it was a very nice game I'm sorry
there any questions because I think I
feel like I went through that kind of
quickly and yeah I think mate was put on
the board yeah I'm pretty sure mate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]